hi there Steve coffin here today I want
to talk about Chinese and about Mark
Zuckerberg Chinese Mark Zuckerberg
recently spoke in front of a group of
students in Beijing and he spoke in
Chinese as he himself stated in his
Facebook account first ever his first
ever Q&A session in Chinese this
generated a certain amount of
controversy
one American commentators said I presume
he's American it's an American review
called foreign policy said he spoke like
a seven-year-old and they got all his
tones wrong on the other hand - on a
Canadian his name is mark I think
something or other said he did very well
and indicates roughly what you can learn
after two to three years of study of
Chinese okay a few comments here first
of all he doesn't speak English I knees
very well
hey speech perhaps as Mark - Ahn said
about as well as you can expect after 33
years maybe I think you can expect more
after 2 to 3 years that's not important
I think it's very important to me that
everyone learns languages for their own
goals and purposes it's not about
performing people tell me that I speak
language a better than some other person
or not as well as some other person it
doesn't matter
I speak my language in order to
communicate some people have more time
to spend some people have less time to
spend marc-eddy smart yeah mark
zuckerberg
communicated he didn't always understand
the question very often that chinese
people didn't understand what he was
saying however there was a human being
to human being communication I have been
in meetings when you know Japanese or
French or other forums that say
businessmen come and address a meeting
and they address it entirely in their
language if they then struggle to speak
in English however poorly they do that's
another level of communication it's a
wonderful thing that he did a that he
communicated in Chinese be that he has
one of the most successful and most
wealthy people in the world
would take the time to learn Chinese
sends a very positive message not only
to the Chinese but to other people who
might get interested in studying Chinese
so there is nothing negative about what
he did it's only positive whatever his
level of Chinese may be who knows he's I
don't know how long he's been studying
Chinese I don't know how many hours a
day he has available for studying
Chinese all of these things influence it
so I am very impressed with what he did
and whether his Chinese is better or
worse than someone else's Chinese
doesn't matter the other issue is what
can be achieved so much of the criticism
I thought his vocabulary wasn't bad I
think where he had a problem was in
comprehension and in his obviously
mastery of the taunt my recommendation
is you know to get the tones and I can
remember from having learned Chinese and
I did it in a very concentrated fashion
in nine months ie was added six seven
hours a day more listening reading
writing talking whatever I could do and
but I listened a lot and if I listened
an awful lot and with regard to the
tones as long as I was trying to
remember the tones for individual words
I was lost I would get three right to
wrong and wrong right what's the throne
here it inhibited inhibited my speaking
you can't get the tones that way the way
you have to get the tones is lots of
listening and capturing sort of phrases
together and and reading out loud while
you're reading Chinese and trying to get
the the tones and gradually getting used
with letting your brain naturally absorb
it one of the best things I did for my
tones was listening to see unsure if any
of you are familiar with Junction that
is a Chinese comic dialogue and there
they exaggerate you have to get the
rhythm of the language all right now
I don't speak just much Chinese now
because I'm busy on you know
russian-ukrainian Korean but I'll switch
into Chinese and I know that when I
Chinese when I'm with Chinese people I
start off with poor tones and they
gradually get better
my tones in Mandarin are better than my
tones in Cantonese because I have had
more practice in matter and so now
Shenzhen was sure it's right here don't
wanna you may well change ambush
wardrobe when that was hands-on Don what
did it take a session - aankia
what way - her shorts haulers and also
doesn't take beyond simply ology so you
have a phrase like biology I don't
remember what the individual poems are
but how do you say not important reality
ok
neutral Rama what are you saying the
short drama just as in English we get
used to a certain tonality which in
English the tones represent emphasis in
the phrase in the sentence or in a
phrase in Chinese they represent the
actual meaning of the word but it's
still the same concept you have to get
used to tones in a context in a group of
phrases and if you hear them often
enough and say them often enough then
gradually you get better and better
and and you can't do that without an
awful lot of listening and in my
particular case I listened to this young
Jean because the rhythm it's almost like
music and you're training your brain
through this intensive listening to
another come to think that I also this
there's a history of the Second World
War
DRN sessions about Dada Dada and for
some reason that guy also exaggerated
the tones and so you get this resonance
you're starting to connect with the
music of the language to me that's how
you learn but it takes an awful lot of
listening and with regard to vocabulary
which is an area that mark could improve
it it's an awful lot of reading so you
need to do those things you can't just
talk all the time obviously when you
have that background once you have done
enough reading listening then you have
to get up and talk and you have to get
out to talk a lot but so and I think a
person who had a program of intensive
listening and reading couple then
eventually with more and more speaking
but speaking not with a teacher on you
know what are we going to talk about
today the weather but actual meaningful
communication with people and
in order to get into meaningful
communication with people you have to
have good comprehension so someone who
had a program much like what I had when
I was studying Chinese with a lot of
listening and reading I think in two to
three years can achieve more than what
Mark Zuckerberg demonstrated in Beijing
so there you have it so it was a very
good thing what he did and I was
impressed that he did it and I was
impressed that he was able to do what he
can do and I respect anyone who learns a
language and I respect their
achievements and people should respect
their own achievements but if you want
to sort of an objective evaluation of
what's Teva belén two to three years
again depending on how much time you put
in and how are you study I think quite a
bit more can be achieved in two to three
years if you are prepared to do what I
did study six seven eight hours a day
major focus on listening and reading
really get into it really throw yourself
into the environment then you can
achieve an awful lot in in one year and
while I think of it I spoke on the
internet once with a fellow from Sweden
who had studied Chinese for one year in
Sweden and I tell you his chinese is
better than mine so and I think mine is
not bad so all I'm saying is a follow
Mark Zuckerburg example learn Chinese if
you do it the right way and you put
enough time in it and if you're
motivated you can achieve an awful lot
even in one year thanks for listening
bye for now